it may be impossible to avoid coming
into contact with the flu virus more
than 120,000 Americans have been
diagnosed with the virus and the flu is
widespread in 48 states
the risk is expected to stay elevated
for weeks one high risk area for the
spread of the virus could be your
workplace dr. Tara Narula shows us why
offices may be a breeding ground for the
flu Tara the morning good morning John
with the flu season now at epidemic
levels with up to 4,000 Americans dying
weekly getting the flu is a risk you
don't want to take and we discovered
it's not just about who you come in
contact with but what we generally do
about three minutes per swab yes
germs good or bad hide in plain sight it
could be human cells animal cells
viruses fungi bacteria Chris Mason a
geneticist at Weill Cornell Medicine is
using a four-step method known as
shotgun sequencing this is basically
taking whatever DNA is there and pulling
it out and then mapping it all to all
the known species the results will tell
us the hotspot areas bacteria and
viruses are hiding including the flu
what are some of the areas in an office
where we might be most susceptible the
areas where there's the most flu and
microbes are really the high touch
surfaces of things like the kitchen sink
door handles elevator buttons and the
places you find the most bacteria that's
the same places you find the most viral
particles right you'll find bacteria and
viruses will come together as a big sort
of microbe cloud that follow you around
the CDC says the influenza virus can
live on some surfaces for up to a day
meaning if you touch a contaminated
surface and then touch your mouth nose
your eyes within that window you're at
risk of infection and a study found that
over a quarter of Americans admit to
coming into work sick so we tested for
common office spots to see where the
dangers lie first the breakroom this is
an area where people touch a lot of
things flash around it could even lead
to ways you know essentially things
could grow because it's a moist enough
area then the conference room basically
cells and viruses and other sort of
entities can build up in the small
porous areas
things like this like a chair in a
conference room or a sofa or couch
fabrics anything yeah it's basically
like a big sponge
Reading area yeah an easy one to
overlook the stair railing this is
really a place where many many hands are
touching especially you know people are
walking moving around it could be when
they start coughing one really good
thing though is that is steel and so the
viruses do not live long on steel
neither do most bacteria and something
most of us can't avoid keyboard which I
imagine is colonized with a lot of
bacteria and viruses yes indeed how
often do you recommend that somebody
wiped down a surface there's a active
flu going around it wouldn't be a bad
idea to clean it every day the swabs
were taken to their lab for testing and
analysis the results they did not detect
any flu but found bacteria and other
viruses the keyboard was the most
contaminated followed by the break room
the railing then the conference room
these findings they say are consistent
with most offices another interesting
result we tested the keyboard after
using a disinfecting wipe and it reduced
more than 91% of bacteria and viruses
Wow
yes get your wipes so another example
use Purell Purell bro yes I mean washing
your hands obviously the best but
sanitizer works well too did you by
chance look at this table
I did not thought that might be American
grounds so to to be continued continued
thank you tear a very good advice there